hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast development of juice and
a line tunable MC to delivery of
therapeutics using probiotics presented
by Nathan Kirk he is a post post
doctoral researcher in the Department of
Pathology and immunology at Washington
University School of Medicine
I am Marjorie Torrance of lab foods and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
we are delighted to bring you this
educational web stand upon presented by
laddies labyrinth is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the green Q&A button located in the
lower left of the presentation window
and type your question into the box that
appears on the screen
well answer as many questions as we have
time for at the end of the presentation
also please notice that you will be
viewing the presentation in the slide
window to enlarge thava note just click
on the screen icon located on the lower
right if you have trouble seeing or hear
in the presentation please click on the
support button at the top right of the
presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know that you're having
a problem this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
button in the bottom left corner and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
Nathan hood and I will now turn the
presentation over to him
thank you very much Marjorie for that
kind introduction I want to thank you
all for viewing this webinar I'm really
honored to have been chosen to present
to you guys today and what I'll be
talking to you about is some of my
postdoctoral work engineering probiotics
to enable them to eventually deliver
therapeutics in a tunable in vivo way so
my upbringing was in chemical
engineering and some of you might want
to know why a chemical engineer would
choose to engineer microbial communities
and my answer to that is that my
criminal communities are actually one of
the most still sort of beautiful
intricate structures that I have the
privilege of seeing what you're seeing
on this slide is are the microbial
communities associated with anaerobic
sludge digestion this is the process by
which micro microbes actually ferment or
organic liquid waste into chemicals it
being more easily processed and in this
image is one granule which is composed
of different microbes and each of these
microbes is state a different color the
aerobic microbes are colored green and
the an oil colored and and it was very
interesting to me to see how to use
microbes Co associated to these
intricate 3d structures now these
microbial communities exist not only in
our industry industrial settings but
also in our body what you're seeing on
these pictures is an image of dental
plaque and it's really exciting because
what the researchers did in this paper
was they took people who hadn't brushed
their teeth for a couple of days and
they scraped the material lining their
chief and imaged that on a microscope
and they stained each species of
bacteria a different color and although
it was extraordinary to me was the fact
that these microbial communities
actually associate into sort of these
the green layer on the outside and the
purple layer on the inside and these
actually represent different micro
species that do different metabolic
functions the microbes on its card in
green are aerobic which makes sense
because they're on the outside of this
plaque and the microbes in football are
the anaerobes and they are inside
because there's no oxygen environment
not only do they form this unique cookie
pile structure they also have if you
look on panel F you'll see honeycomb
structures along the filaments made by
these proven bacteria so the fact that
these microbes are able to self
associate into these intricate nano
structures kind of really motivated me
to get into this field now these exist
not only in our teeth but also in our
gut and so if we zoom in on what a
bacteria sees when it's in our net
you'll see an image where different
players within the gut or same different
colors so in balloon here are the now
this is a mouse gut is a mouse
epithelial cells in green is the newest
that these epithelial cells are
secreting and this mucous serves three
different functions it not only provides
food to the bacteria and it also
protects the host from bacterial
potential pathogenic bacteria but also
lubricates the flow of material as it
passes along the gut so the mucus is
actually very important to bacterial
metabolism as we'll see in a few slides
if we sort of take a broader view of the
gut and we stain different types of
bacteria based on their sort of
taxonomic identification their species
you see that there are many different
types of bacteria that existed in the
gut and here there's gaining the
bacteria Alex and the Firmicutes within
the guy certain types of bacteria
associated towards the lumen or the
interior of the gut and those are
fermenting you know undigested material
whereas other bacteria associated with
the mucus and are actually fermenting
the mucus as a food source as sort of a
fun exercise what I did is I took mouse
eco material and we suspended it in
phosphate buffered saline to see whether
these bacteria are actually
metabolically active and efficacy though
on a microscope and what you're seeing
on this movie is the image that I saw on
my microscope
you see a lot of bacteria swimming
around and fecal material many much of
this might be due to Brownian motion but
you'll also see bacteria that appear to
be moving in a more directed fashion
they're kind of zipping around this this
image very quickly and they're clearly
metabolically active within fecal
material and I just thought it was
amazing to see the diversity of shapes
structures and behaviors exhibited by
these bacteria so not only are these
bacterial microbiome Ubese beautiful but
they also serve a very important
biological function so if we take a look
at the human body itself the human body
contains a diverse array of genes 23,000
genes products myriad cells in a very
large biomass contained within the large
intestine though is this diverse
microbial community that is similarly
amazing it has much much order to
magnitude more genes encoded within it
than the human body does it has about
the same number of cells as the human
body but it also it exists in a biomass
that is not insignificant it could be
used for doing metabolic and what it
actually does is it takes that
undigested material from the gut and
provides about 10% of our daily caloric
intake through digestion of this fiber
is synthesizes vitamins for us from that
unadjusted material and in particular
vitamins E and vinyls kale just by being
in this nutrient-rich environment and
not doing anything particularly
pathogenic it also resists patent
colonization excitingly the membership
that this microbiome is dynamic it can
change over daily and almost in yearly
timescales as well in addition to its
natural variation it can also be
perturbed in a more directed way through
probiotics and fecal microbiota
transfers
so this dynamic nurse is part of why I'm
interested in it because you can
eventually engineer this microbial
community so what is this microbial
community look like in healthy
individuals and healthy individuals if
we look at just the bacteria than the
gut you see a large diversity of
memberships so on the sort of side
graph here what you're seeing are the
different phyla that are the contained
that make up this microbial community
you see Bacteroides you see Firmicutes
using proteobacteria and varying ratios
within the gut all of the microbial
species abundance is add up to one in
this graph so this is a well to the
abundance measure the bacteria these are
the types of bacteria that are commonly
associated with from the fermentation of
long-chain polysaccharides and the
prettier bacteria are the more famous
numbers of which include eco light for
example and those are exist as well and
then within healthy individuals so if we
go to the next bit you can also see
fungi fungi exists and healthy
individuals guts these exist in commonly
known genera including Candida
now Candida is commonly associated in
you know human in the medical literature
with yeast infections but there's also
non-pathogenic versions of Candida which
exist as well or at least they don't
there are pathogens that are not
contributing to the infection there's
also Saccharomyces involved oh my gut
and you might know this genus of fungi
as the one responsible for this also if
we take a look at the gastrointestinal
tract in relation to other body sites so
other body sites also have ESET version
equivalent communities to see if the
Kathryn Testament book Eliza's for a
particular region of this non
dimensional space so this graph is a
principal component analysis spot and it
takes all of the multi-dimensional data
for the different microbial species
abundances and condense it down to one
point graph now points that are close
together on this graph indicate very
similar species distributions
whereas ones that are further apart
indicate my crew go species
distributions that are very different so
if you look at this graph in sort of a
qualitative way you'll see the Kathryn
test on tract is very different from our
oral microbiome or even our skin
microbiome interestingly your genital
tract
exist kind of in the middle between the
gastrointestinal tract and skin if we
look at this microbiome in Croatian -
disease you see that individuals with
the disease listed here have been shown
to have microbial species abundances
that are very very different from what
you see in a healthy individual in
particular obesity autism and colon
cancer are very hot topic issues that
people have shown that if you you know
not only is this micro species microbe
Oh give me different its microbiome
different but also if you give a disease
microbiome to a healthy in general Mouse
you see you'll see the showing of
disease like symptoms so the fact that
the microbiome is so important to health
and so important to disease indicates if
the gut microbiome is actually kind of
like an organ in the human body and the
upshot of this is that this is the only
organ within the human body
that can be engineered without surgery
because you can do these sort of things
like get probiotics or people microbiome
transfers so what type of things can be
due to they've got to enable to the
engineered so one of these things is a
probiotic these are a line of
microorganisms that improve got function
these are defined species so I'm showing
you three examples of different types of
programs which people will take one of
them is e.coli nestle shown on the left
here it's a large intestinal prokaryote
so it's a exist in the large intestine
it's effective for treatment of
inflammatory bowel disease diarrhea and
constipation it's actually marketed in
Europe as middle floor and it's one of
the few sort of probiotics which has
been clinically shown to have improved
the ability to treat these sort of hero
bowel disease infections
there's also lactobacillus rhamnosus
this is bacteria that lives in the small
intestine it's also affected for a
variety of conditions and I want to draw
your attention to Sacramentans Balaji
this is a eukaryote that exists in a
large intestine
and it's effective against many
different types of pathogens it actually
binds to and inhibits the toxicity
associated with c-diff h pylori and
Salmonella typhi so not only are
prokaryotes very useful products but
these sort of neglected eukaryotes are
also effective products as well now
unfortunately these probiotics are sort
of natural organisms they have a certain
amount of limitations to them if you
want to use them for therapies one of
them is a low residence time to the gut
but I'm showing here is a graph of E
coli missile abundance over time in
individuals who took this probiotic so
as you can see as the week's go on in
this and the study the percentage of
individuals who were positive for equina
so steadily dropped and so this is a
problem because E coyness those commonly
taken for treatment of inflammatory
bowel disease and which is a chronic
condition so if you have a chronic
condition you want a chronic treatment
and products you're not satisfied that
criteria
the other problem is you have a limited
amount of expression control with these
probiotics so if you want to deliver a
particular therapeutic dose of a gene
product to the gut of an individual and
in this case I'm showing a mouse for
experimental simplicity you only really
have a couple of options you can either
make it very lowly expressed or you can
sort of ramp up the expression to some
high level that you're not really sure
what it is so you have a limited ability
to tune this potentially toxic gene
product so it might have a therapeutic
window that you don't want to get out of
and so you need very detailed expression
control in this case so in response to
these limitations in micro-thin my
postdoc I've been developing several
transformative technologies for the gut
one is to improve the rate at which
probiotics and colonize and the other is
improving the resolution with which we
can tune a gene product so in case this
wasn't clear in the previous graph the y
axis shows sort of a phenotypic response
and relationship dose
and so hopefully there'll be some
optimum that coincides with a
therapeutic window of that drug hey you
wanted to these tooth things might seem
quite distinct but in reality they have
they share the common payment high
throughput screen and to enable their
their ends so before I get into the
colonization enhancement aim of my my
work I want to first think the people I
work with as you as you see on the top
view from left to right
Taran's crops myself sherry son Arthur
arrow and drew Gasparini
were all very instrumental to the
continued development of this work on
the bottom you see Mitch possess key
lolli Gibson being wrong and of course
my advisor captain Don tests were
continued to be instrumental in both the
conception and trend development of this
work so when we envisioned improving
duck colonization we had a lot of ideas
about what might impede an organism from
living a new organism to living within
the cotton there's of course the
physical flow of material more than we
got
that pushes the bacterium from beginning
to end there's the there's phage with
viruses with them to gut that can
predate on these on these newcomers as
well as the immune system of the host
itself I can interfere with a newcomer
finally there's a existing metabolic
Network that certain that the existing
bacteria play a part in which may
exclude a newcomer from participating so
this is all very abstract but if you
want to sort of make the analogy to move
into a new place bacteria need to learn
the cuisine of a new location when they
go into going to adopt a guinea to have
a
there's actually a bacterial language
barrier that they need to overcome in
terms of interspecies signaling and each
competition is like finding a job they
need to know or they need to be able to
convert metabolic material from one form
to another
downhill fashion in order to make their
living and begun and there's also a
local disease that they need to gain no
resistance there's a lot of barriers to
to to living in a new place for a
bacterium and without knowing which one
was the sort of rate limiting step we
opted for a non rational approach to
engineering this string now what does
that mean in order to figure out sort of
how we engineer bacteria Vietnam
national approach we have to know how we
engineered bacteria in general so as you
guys are all probably well aware DNA is
sort of the recipe book of the cell the
gene that encodes particular new product
is transmitting messenger RNA is
transcribed into a protein which
performs some function within the cell I
like to make the analogy to a cookbook
where a gene itself is like a cookbook
right you never really take into the
kitchen that contains all minute
necessary instructions for the thing
you're trying to make you'll transcribe
that book onto a sticky note and take
that into your kitchen to make you or to
make you make your dish and your dish is
something that you would like to eat so
the question that we had to answer for
ourselves was how can you find new genes
that do interesting things and this is a
we wanted to make this is a
high-throughput and non biased approach
as possible so if we may continue with
the analogy of finding new recipes if we
want to find a new recipe that is
something that we launched how would we
do it by good course well the way we
would potentially do it is take all the
recipe books that we had access to and
take random pages from each one so just
randomly tear pages out we have to give
these random pages to the best cook that
we know the cook to sort of make these
into an actual dish and the best cook I
know is my grandma so let's say we
totally B's recipes to my grandma and
have her cook what's included within
them now some of these recipes are going
to give us the food that we want and in
this case it could be the lasagne
but it could be other foods that maybe
me weren't interested in or it could be
nothing at all in this case and then
keep plate
now if we do this enough times we're
gonna get lasagna we know more than once
and figure out sort of what constitutes
we'll assign you a recipe and learn from
that so in a similar sort of way we're
going to search bacteria to identify
genes enabling point a soul to colonize
a large intestine so instead of
cookbooks in this case we have bacterial
genomes and these bacterial genomes are
contained within fecal material from an
healthy human individuals only this we
took these spiegel samples and extracted
the DNA that they contain these are our
recipes and we shared them to 3 to 5 KB
chunks now when we did this to sort of
narrow our search down into pathways or
single genes that would allow us to
improve gut colonization we took this
DNA and gave it to our cook or in this
case it's a probiotic equina so that
will transcribe and translate the DNA
encoded within these shared products and
the way we identify whether these gene
products encode improved compensation
capacity as we deliver these this
product library into mice now these mice
will shed the delivery e.coli nestled
over time the poor colonizers will be
shed quite early and so in early time
points Mouse fecal material will contain
pretty much everybody however as time
goes on the good colonizers will be sort
of latched on to the gut and be
producing progeny and those will be
enriched in the fecal material of these
- at later time points so by amplifying
the DNA that's contained within its
fecal material that's specific to coli
we can sequence it and figure out what
was encoded within the fragments that
stuck around and we can learn that so if
that was a bit too technical for you
basically what we're doing is taking ten
to the seventh genes or gene products
from gut metagenomes and narrowing them
down to one to ten hits that are good
colonizing factors
the exciting part of this approach is
the fact that you can take the same
basic technique and make it sort of
reductionist or learn different things
based on how you structure it so in this
case what we can do is a reductionist
approach where you can take the simplest
possible way we can think of flop
colonization or the most complex
possible way to do people for
colonization so what do I mean by that
the first experiment activities in
German free mice these might have you
know native gut flora the size equal I
of course that we deliver to them and it
really models just the host E coli
interaction so what is it is necessary
for colonization in that context and we
can add complexity to this in sort of an
iterative fashion so it can give it
different diets for example human diet
or we can add different members of its
gut and in terms of these conventional
mice they actually have a they got
microbiome that contains other gut
bacteria as well so we can add
complexity and learn what was necessary
to colonize at each step to figure out
what you know what's necessary to
colonize so before I get into the actual
results I just I didn't want to touch on
a little bit the fact that we did our
experiments in jumping mice and this is
sort of a it's a team's been around for
a while but may not be familiar to
everybody and when it is what it does is
it takes mice that are born germ-free
and it houses them in these sort of
plastic bubbles these are self-contained
plastic levels they have their own sort
of sterilized air supply that comes in
and air sterilized when it comes out
everything that's given to these mice in
terms of food water bedding etc is
delivered via a sterilized cylinder and
given to the Givens of the mice so
everything is sterilized when it comes
in so as when it comes out and we you
know we bleach this plastic cylinder to
make sure that no bacteria are currently
residing on it I mean actually never
touched the animals ourselves we use
these gloves to make sure that these
mice exist in an environment that is
completely you know of known bacterial
composition in this case and this is
very powerful approach because we can do
is do experiments on germ-free animals
animals without any microbes living in
or on them you can do experiments with
animals that have a known vacuole
composition so you can take these
individual microbial species and culture
then in the lab and then you know you
have a handful of sort of synthetic
microbiome it you can do experiments on
and that's sort of the bottom-up
approach and the top-down approach to
that would be to use human fecal
material from individuals who are
diseased or healthy and deliver that to
those mice and see their effects on
mouse phenotype communities with mice
and people have done you know obviously
the complexity increases as you increase
the size of the animal but it's a very
powerful approach to answer hypothesis
driven questions on the gut microbiome
so let's get into the actual results we
did our first experiment and completely
germ-free animals that were eating a
mouse diet we had six animals in this
case on day zero we advised our library
this was a ten to the seventh member
pulling us along great work every
different every member of this library
had a different gene product from the
from another genome we took fecal
pellets over time over the course of
three weeks at the end of three weeks we
collected seco contents and this is the
different colored material here what was
always really exciting on all of our six
months we saw enrichment of a handful of
gene products to near 100 percent
abundance so on the y-axis of all these
graphs is the stacked abundance or the
cumulative abundance of the DNA
fragments been showing so and 100
percent means that all we coli continued
that Mouse have the fragments that are
listed on on the graph and time is on
the x-axis and over all of our six
months we had excitingly the same five
DNA fragments enriched for enriched in
these mice so the all these fragments
are colored consistently so the blue
fragment is the exact same gaming
sequence in all six mice and from our
tuna the seventh member library every
single one of our mice that you chose
was able to enrich for that particular
team pocket making of this blue and the
orange gene products are
very important for colonization we also
saw a lot of other gene products which
were very important so before I get into
the actual sequence of those genes but
I'm going to show you is our next
experiment Lily took piecing or we took
germ-free mice again and house them with
different human relevant diets so I'm
showing another graph here which is
similar to that shown above where we
have 15 here free mice and they were ate
a human diet now this human diet is sort
of loosely defined where it's a it's
actually a high carb high fat diet so
it's more mimicking and Western type
diet than anything else and we wanted to
do this because we were interested in
you know probiotics that the differences
between a mouse got a mouse diet and a
human diet they also added one of
several prebiotics in this case we used
been if I were anyone or just
controllers no prebiotic and prebiotics
are long-chain Sakurai's that actually
pass through the gut undigested and make
it into the large intestine and they
serve as food sources for the so we were
envisioning that these prebiotics would
actually select for probiotics that were
dependent upon them for growth in that
case the combination of a prebiotic and
a probiotic is called a symbiotic what
we saw was also very very interesting in
this case you know like before and all
our replicate mice we saw a the same
types of DNA fragments enriched in each
one so and they also so in this case and
benefiber you see the same colors
appearing again and again those
replicate those indicate the same gaming
sequences are recovered in those mice
you also see that over time over the
course of our five week experiment we
were able to recover we were able to
sort of capture nearly 100% of the
diversity and those and those large
intestines with these those it was
efficient is that between arms we got a
different set of DNA fragments recovered
in each one so in benefiber versus
England for example you've got very
different DNA fragments recovered this
was indicated to us that maybe these DNA
fragments are specializing for the
particular diets if he's myself eating
the other thing if I was interesting was
that there was one fragment that was
recovered in all 15 Mike's even though
these mice were separately caged
they were able to recover the same
purple DNA fragment in each one and this
indicates us potentially a generalist
DNA fragment that was sort of able to
colonize regardless of diet so we were
very interested in these sort of
generalist fragments that we recovered
in this experiment as well as the
experiment prior we then sequenced these
fragments and discovered that these
fragments actually encode carbohydrate
utilization Llosa so on the side here
I'm showing the fragment name is and the
quick addicted source of that fragment
based on the blast service the MD
fragments are those diamonds that were
recovered from our experiment and the HD
or human diet fragment was the
generalist that you recovered in a
second experiment on the graph on the
scale is the sort of scale the weight
scale of these fragments in light blue
is the promoter that is driving
expression of these fragments and every
arrow we contained in these fragments is
a different gene and these chains are
colored based on their predicted
annotation in the model excitingly
most of these fragments contain glycosyl
hydrolases family feeling tubes these
are enzymes that are predicted to
hydrolyze
sucrose into its constituent monomers
Super's is actually a disaccharide that
the core nestle can't actually utilize
these are exciting also located proximal
to created transporters so we were
excited to think that maybe
sugar transport as well as hydrolysis
was something that was limiting in corn
a cell phone call from colonizing so
what we did is we did a couple of sort
of directed growth experiments in
minimal media with different carbon
sources as they're suitable you know
carbon source in order to see what which
one in particular these guys
allowing consumption of what we saw as
expected was that sucrose was one carbon
source that allowed growth that allowed
privilege growth of these fragments over
a no-fat in control so no time in
control is shown in green and what
you're looking for is growth above the
green line in this case in sucrose the
green line is here and you see that all
of our game a fragments were except the
one were able to grow faster on sucrose
then this mel fragment controls as well
there are no timing control could be
thought of as a wild type missile but we
also saw other carbon sources like
raffinose and also stateõs which were
important for i've actually enabled
privileged growth of these fragment
containing missiles versus a wild type
and they actually enabled faster growth
on these more complex carbon sources
than sucrose which is very simple we did
see one fragment the one fragment mc4
that grew faster in galactose was the
only famine that occur faster in
galactose and it could not utilize any
of the other three carbon sources so
between these four carbon sources we
kind of figured out what these carbon
sources are doing and if you look at the
actual structure of these
polysaccharides you see a conserved
theme where every one of these has a
sucrose head and several glucoses sort
of trailing off toward the end and this
makes sense because potentially you know
the annotator was telling us that yes
hydrolysis of this yukos fructose bond
was very important but maybe these
different fragments are adapting toward
either more simple or more complex
private sources now what we don't know
is whether these carbon sources are
derived in their diet or if they're are
derived and more experiments at least
appear that out so next what we did was
we took these fragments and we wanted to
figure out whether they would enable
condensation of a more complex Mouse
microbiome so we took all of our twenty
generalist and specialist
that we identified in prior experiments
and we clone them out and transform them
into niihka lino soil and in a fresh
stream this would allow us to sort of
account for any genome evolution that
had occurred in previous experiments and
just have say the actual fragment itself
in terms of what it would do to
compensation and we compared this to the
connotation of an empty vector
containing equally missing in two
separate arms of a mouse experiment
these mice were either containing the
fragment library itself or the empty
vector wild-type McMissile what we did
was we took 24 specific pathogen free
mice and we allowed them to first you
know yeah sort of equilibrated in their
in their habitats but we also did we had
to give them antibiotics three days
before the modular of our eco life that
was because conventional - after you
have it's a bit high cons asian
resistance to eco anisole they will not
the clients will can't colonize at all
and use mice without prior antibiotic
knockdown this actually kills a lot of
the resident microflora so this is
definitely a simpler sort of a less
complex case and a conventional mouse
but it's more complex than from three
Mouse so interestingly sort of stepping
stone toward colonization of a
conventional Mouse microbiome in the
benefiber arm we saw something quite
exciting where the fragment containing
koi is able to colonize to a higher
abundance at the end of our experiment
then any of our empty vector containing
the coli strains were we did this by
saying the intestinal contents at the
end of five weeks and we saw that in the
proximal small intestine so beginning of
the small intestine as well as in the
cecum and colon the e.coli that is
contained within the acquire that
contains our fragments was able to
colonize much more robustly
then the empty vector continued I was
and so we're trying to figure out which
ones of these 20 fragments enabled
colonization and also why because that
is also a very important question so
this is an exciting result that
motivates us to continue
working on this so that's like that's
occurrence has that project the aim of
this was to improve programming ethicacy
by increasing gun persistence and we
used an approach called functional
metagenomics to identify causation
factors we identified that sucrose and
galactose realization were very
important for survival and we also found
that these same colonization factors
that you can isolate in a germ-free case
also translate to a conventional Mouse
or specific position free Mouse and
allows colonization there as well
so looking forward excited to use this
approach to identify improved colonizers
and other body sites we can envision
delivering to other organs you know the
skin small intestine stomach etc
identify those bacteria that exists
better in those cases as long as not
only frequent more strains that
naturally exist in those as well
in those settings as well so let's move
on to the promoter engineering are the
lists of this work I first want to
really thank my undergraduate who worked
with me on this project as name is Evan
Conde out and he was a fantastic sort of
colleague to bounce ideas off of and
really get this project off the ground
so well when we thought of this project
we we have a particular problem right
what we really want to do is deliver a
particular therapy gene product at
different doses and to emmaus to see
what effect was most effective for the
mouse's health now this team partner
could be you know a recombinant antibody
or a particular gene that allows
consumption of a novel dietary material
and there is likely a therapeutic window
for this gene product which you don't
want to go out of and it was likely an
optimal gene expression so the way you
normally would do this you know if you
had a library of promoters as you take
you know several different promoters
ones with different known strengths and
put it in front of you the coding region
of your gene and deliver that in two
years
and that's that's what would that's the
experiment you would like to do in order
to tell you whether this will be or not
unfortunately we don't really have known
strength promoters we have a lot of
promoters that we could test but we
don't really know which ones would work
or not and how well they work in the gut
reason why is because normally with this
what people will do is we'll take these
promoters and you'll put in in the in
vitro so you take a test tube and you
can take you know three test tubes per
promoter and you say it's activity via
flows coming to your qpcr to identify
how strong each one of your candidate
promoters really is
unfortunately this works very well or in
vitro but not in vivo in vivo if you
made the simple analogy of one test tube
equals one Mouse that really gives you
too many mice because in normal cases
you want to be testing you know tens to
hundreds of promoters at a time and you
don't want to be using mice in that way
want to use in a smarter way so we need
a high throughput in people promoter
analysis approaches so the way in which
that I decided to do this was through
the following method what we would do is
we would take a promoter library that we
wanted to characterize in vivo and for
every promoter that we would test we'd
Kelowna in front of a reporter gene and
there'd be a unique mapping between a
that promoter and a promoter specific
barcode at the end of your gene of
interest so you have a promoter and for
every promoter you might test you have a
unique DNA barcode and this is a unique
DNA sequence that doesn't really
interfere with gene expression but tells
you which promoter that came from what
you could then do is generate your
library of E coli strains
using each one of those promoters every
eco I strain has a different promoter
that's driving into a polar gene give
those to your mouse so in this case you
don't need one Mouse promoter or three
months book promoter you need three mice
per library of perverse wishes that much
there's a very substantial reduction in
gene expression and then over time you
can copy you can recover
fecal contents
contents I've intestinal contents and
recover the you know the from your
expression from that and I'll get into
how we actually get that later on but
this is sort of the high-level view of
what I'm doing is we're taking a
promoter centric approach for
non-science to a library centric
approach and you can measure many many
promoter constructs and very then what
you can do is you can recover DNA and
RNA from those organs so the RNA
measures the about the sort of gene
expression abundance and importantly the
barcode that I inserted after each
promoter is going to be present within
that Holliday
it's also to be present within the DNA
in that contract
the DNA is will measure the abundance of
that bacteria on its own within the gut
so you I calculating the number of each
barcode in the RNA and dividing that by
the number of each bar code in the can a
you get a measure of promoter strength
now the advantage of this approach is
that is very high throughput so you can
measure you know hundreds of promoters
in this an experiment and it's also host
and habitat agnostic so you can take
this approach and deliver a gene
products for eukaryotes for example and
she sacrifices Velarde and you can do it
and get me how it has like the skin
microbiome etc so it's a very flexible
approach so the first thing we need to
do is identify which promoters reminds
you characterize what we did was we used
parts previously used for synthetic
biology in particular a twenty member
constitutive library developed by Chris
Anderson we also included adjustable
promoters by different different small
molecule and users like AI pkg arabinose
and hydro tetracycline we also only use
an inverter circuit a rapid ascent at
other which I'll get into a little bit
but these synthetic promoters is
specific consented promoters don't like
Chris Anderson span a wide range this is
the reported activities of these
promoters and would allow us to see
whether this map Tacoma well to the
in-video case or not we also took known
Ecoline Ezell promoters and the way we
cared we
define these was through a human gut
minute transcriptomic data had eight
subjects we extracted the reads
naturally in coli genes and we took the
read count and divided by gene length in
order to identify which teams were the
most work in order to characterize the
expression level of each gene we wanted
their range so we took the highest level
of expression and the lowest level of
expression and we took divided that
range into 20 logs based bins within
each bin we chose the gene which
satisfied two criteria one of its which
had the lowest between subject
expression variation so we wanted it to
perform the same way between different
subjects and also was immediately
downstream of the promoter of a we
wanted in terms of bacteria if you have
an operon with many many genes we wanted
the gene that was most proximal to it in
order to gain the most accurate measure
of that promoters activity so here are
the candidates that we identified we
have some genes that are very high the
recorded expression and something very
very low expression so we were excited
to figure out okay do these actually
perform the same way what we did is we
took these promoters and we clone them
in front of a green fluorescent protein
or other gene beasts known missle
promoter as well as the synthetic
promoters and we characterized that
expression via flow cytometry what we
found was that the motors that we have
cloned in span an under load range can
you calling us all now it's important to
know that this is in vitro growth in LB
bra very very different from the and be
the case but they stand on 100 fold
range and so this gives us a promising
starting point to do for the
characterizations of interest we did
find that our flow cytometry sort of
limited our ability to gain access to
the veloute weak promoters so if we look
at the anderson promoters and we
correlate on the y-axis with what we
observed versus the x-axis which is what
has been recorded we find a good
correlation for the strong promoter
but as the promoters themselves become
very very weak you see a sort of it
scaling off of the correlation and that
could indicate a limited resolution
about flow cytometry and very very low
expression models so a more
high-resolution approach is necessary
there this also limited our ability to
figure out when there are needed missile
promoters will performing as expected
because we have our on the y-axis
flow cytometry data and on the x-axis to
the reported data and when you have a
correlation that looks like this you
know one of your methods is not really
accurate and I think it's because of
those Commodore is not doing a good a
good job at this range so we need
something more like qPCR or potentially
this barcode measurement approach to
identify what's going on we recovered
the fact that these inducible promoters
function as expected actually the p lac
promoter doesn't work very well in this
so actually i think what's going on here
is that the missile is actually being
Auto induced by components within the LV
broth so lb broth is not the best broth
to use for the P lac promoter bad is a
promoter that's induced by ravenous and
we saw that at different levels of
arabinose strongly x-axis we were able
to get you know steadily increased
expression of the y-axis so for the P
bat motor works very well and peanuts
important because arabinose is generally
not digested very well as it passes
through the gut or a pass through small
intestine so that it can pass largely
unimpeded to the large intestine we can
then use promoters that you would like
to turn on at certain times we also did
an exciting experiment where you use
this pee bag pet our inverter now this
has the opposite behavior to the pee bag
promoter whereas
ravenous increases the expression
actually goes down and the way this this
is done is that your pee bag promoter
which is induced by revenues actually
induces expression
Prester protein to our this tech are
creating habits turned on continues
continually represses your record in
this case of gel GFP so as ppad
increases GFP decreases and this is
known as an inverter or an op gate and
both of these sort of inverted turning
on and turning off are very very
important for so it's exciting that they
worked in a probiotic we found is that
this choice of strain influences
promoter strength so in missile
activation on the y-axis and a normal
lab Trinity coli as shown on the x-axis
so just even if it's the exact same
media conditions aux-in growth
conditions we saw that the strain itself
actually doesn't influence rank so this
is sort of a motivator to why we need to
do this in people measurement case we
found excited me that barcodes the
addition of a barcode does not affect
the expression so this is based on the
fact that we need a promotional barcode
at the end of your gene of interest and
so the we have a reasonable concern that
this addition of a random DNA sequence
this is only six base pairs and 50% GC
at the end of your gene may impact
expression to some level what we saw was
that the but that wasn't the case though
we saw largely and within hair within
experimental error largely the same
expression with and without the barcode
that was very very good for us and
indicated that the barcode itself would
provide a allow us to accurately measure
promoter strength so let's get into the
actual nitty-gritty details of how we do
our experiments you take your promoter
library and it tarnished Civic barcode
and I hope you can see this well there's
a blacks mark on our on my slide but
that's okay I'll kind of show you what I
mean what's what's going on is that you
have this barcode encoded on either your
DNA or RNA and after you make your
complementary or cDNA you can bend PCR
that DNA with primers that hybridize to
your intended product
in this case it's our reporter gene and
our our terminator afterward and they
will amplify this barcode these primers
contain not only sample specific
barcodes shown in purple to tell you
it's about two item multiplex your
experiments on the same sequence in Lane
but also these things called unique
molecular right into fires these are
shown in orange and either actually you
know random base pairs that are added
doing all your synthesis where so that
every single primer molecule actually
has a different sequence in that region
and that allows you to uniquely identify
be starting molecules in your PCR so
what you do is a small three base pair
or three cycle amplification using these
primers and that basically allows you to
uniquely prime one set of primers to one
template and that will uniquely link
with a sample barcode and of course your
your promoter specific barcode and then
once you have your unique identifiers
placed you can then use Illumina
sequencing primers to amplify that
region and then sequence it in this case
what we did is we drew this whole
process we generated a PCR product that
was two hundred and twenty seven base
pairs in length it's very important to
gel extract this product as a lot of
grammar language that can form during
your PCR but you want to get rid of but
by counting your the number of unique
identifiers you can then get a measure
of the strength so how do we do this
computationally we first take our reads
that we got off flight sequencer we trim
them to the desired length we use a
program called you search to merge
paired reads together so we have reads
going one direction one the other
direction they actually overlap at some
rate at some rate and you can use a
program to correct errors in sequencing
that way we use a custom Python script
to count for every promoter and sample
barcode combination the number of unique
molecular data files you'd observe and
what it's important to note that instead
of counting the number of businesses of
each promoter barcode it actually
identifiers because that is they need to
correct for potential PCL biases during
them application and then you divide
your on a abundance by DNA abundance to
get promoter activity the first thing we
want to do is make sure this type of
thing was accurate or not so we do the
standard curve and what this does is we
take each promoter and we give it the
same input abundance into a method we're
looking to identify whether your
promoters are sort of randomly giving
you different measurements out or
they're giving a waking thought you were
going to get and this movie what we saw
was quite was not as what we expected
what we saw is using this approach that
the different barcodes we were using
actually greatly impacted the efficiency
of recovery of that barcode computation
that you're after sequencing so some of
our what you're seeing on the y-axis is
the bias so this is the amount of
barcode or unique identifiers what we
observed divided by how many we expected
on the x axis is the promoter itself and
that promoter is we're not really
mentioned that promoter measuring its
barcode here but what we saw was very
interesting no matter what template
concentration that we started out with
we did a two long dilution in template
concentration you got the same type of
bias for every barcode and we also saw
very high error bars here
these were three independent experiments
were on different lanes of our sequencer
different preps of our barcodes which
indicated to us that this thought could
bias was something intrinsic to this
method and not random negative to us
that we could actually use this as our
standard curve and divide out any sort
of the signal that we got from our
sequencer by this bias to get the true
mention about DNA sequence now we tested
that was through the use of a sort of a
actual curve where we took different
mixes of our promoter so the promoters
drone on the
y-axis and we saw we'll be able to do is
ever give a uniform distribution or have
some distributions where some were high
and some are low or somewhere and you
know in the middle etcetera and what we
should be able to do is take a mix one
is our standard and recapitulate the
expected amounts of mixes tutors file
and these are like different types of
promoter strengths you might observe in
different samples what we saw was that
indeed this approach really does allow
you to get at the correct input
abundance using your bias you observe in
a standard curve so this standard curve
method is something that's a little bit
underutilized in the menu in which area
but it's very important to get accurate
results because you can use that curve
to really determine what your with the
correct absolute abundance of your
sample is so that's the current sorry
that's the current status of that
project we're currently excited to do it
on in actual in vitro in people cases
but where we saw so far is that the
strain influences promoter strength the
barcodes themselves do not influence
reverse rate the barcode is used for
measurement but the bug codes do exhibit
a consistent PCR bias and that's
something that is very important because
a lot of amplicon sequencing is could
potentially be affected by PCR bias if
this is if this is true we observe
accurate measurement across a 3 log
range if we if we use this block good
bias as our as a correction and looking
forward I want to use this method and
I'm excited to use this method in in
vitro with different media conditions
different oxygenation conditions and
correlate that to what we observe in
vivo different host diet and microbiome
effects as well so I want to thank you
for your for listening to me talk I
talked about two things today
one was enhancing the colonization of
probiotics with functional genomics and
the other part was doing promoter
engineering using - with barcode
sequencing based approach together
hopefully these two methods will allow
us to open new valves to treat disease
using living
three vehicles and will allow the
activity of these vehicles to be
precisely controlled to your therapeutic
window of interest before I end I want
to thank the people who I worked with
not only directly on these projects but
also in the labs that I worked in I mean
particularly the doctors labs shown here
as composed of wonderful people who are
great to talk to and you know do science
with as well as the funding agencies at
NIH for funding myself as well as the
project that I worked on I want to give
a quick plug for my future directions
coming January 2018 I'm going to be
starting my independent lab at NC State
University so if you are interested in
collaboration or just simply chatting
about that happy to talk to that about
that as well so thank you very much for
your attention and I'll turn it over to
questions now thank you
Thank You dr. Nathan Kirk for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window type
your question into the box that appears
on your screen and click on the send
button
well answer is many of your questions as
we have time for let's get started our
first question is in your colonization
experiment did you observe or look for
any horizontal gene transfer occurring
thank you for that question it's a great
question and we did not look for it
during our experiments but it's
something very important because you can
imagine that improving the colonization
potential of a probiotic may at some
point in the future allow transfer of
that genetic material to happen to a
pathogen and we wanted to avoid that so
what we were making sure to be careful
of was whether the annotation of our
recovery gene patents was a known
virulence factor for a pathogen we did
not want to confer virulence water to
our probiotic but it's a fascinating
question that it should be looked for in
future and future experiments and you
can envision you know different ways to
reduce corazon gene transfer given that
this know your different engineering
approaches as well but thank you very
much for that question
thank you our next question is in our
colonization experiment did you look for
genomic evolution of your host strain as
your selection proceeded thank you again
for that I there's a great question I
think
genomic evolution is something that is
critical to take account take into
account we try to take it into account a
little bit during our during our second
experiment where we transformed these
strains into a new fresh genetic
background but genetic genomic
rearrangements will be very exciting to
look into and we're currently looking
into it right now when we take the
strains of your covering during
selection and doing whole genome
sequencing to identify whether there are
equal I missile genes which are either
inactivated or actually engineered by
the by selection to improve colonization
so that's a great question and something
that were actively looking into you
mentioned the use of unique molecular
identifiers in your promoter Engineering
College
did you test to see whether including
those improve the accuracy of your
method so that's a great question unique
l'affaire identifiers or something that
has been used a lot in the work through
our sequencing field and it hasn't
gained a lot of traction in the
microbiome yet so I wanted to test it
out to see if it worked what we saw when
I went to analyze my data was that the
unique identifiers whether I counted the
number of promoter specific barcodes
themselves or the number identifiers I
got a very similar result so it
indicates that at least in my control
experiments they didn't matter a whole
lot I'm excited to retest that sort of
idea and my in vitro and in vivo
experiments given that there might be
reduced abundances of different DNA
species and also maybe more PCR cycles
involved which may
and being sorted pcl by bias you get so
I guess my answer that question is hold
your thought and maybe it'll be I would
like to once again thank dr. Nathan Hurd
for his presentation I would also like
to thank Bob Lutz for making today's
educational Bobcats possible before we
go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through December 2017
you will receive an email from laberd's
letting you know when this webcast will
be available for replay please share
that announcement with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live with
that
that's all for now and thank you for
joining us we hope to see you again soon
goodbye